se espera que este miércoles se empiece
a restablecerse el tránsito de personas
y de bienes entre el reino unido y
francia- suspendido desde el domingo por
la aparición aquí en gran bretaña de un
nuevo tipo de coronavirus el acuerdo
alcanzado establece que los primeros en
viajar por tierra mar y aire serán
ciudadanos franceses residentes y
viajeros esenciales también establece
que quienes quieran viajar deben
presentar una prueba negativa del
coronavirus 72 horas antes del viaje en
el caso de los conductores de camiones y
de tractomulas surge una pregunta
logística en dónde y quién hará estas
pruebas lo cierto es que aquí en
reinounido la situación es bien
preocupante hay al menos tres mil
camiones apostados a lo largo y ancho de
la autopista en el puerto de dover no
han podido moverse y la preocupación
entre la población es que va a suceder
con los alimentos frescos las frutas y
las verduras cuyo 50% proviene de países
europeos la gente ya está saliendo a los
supermercados a hacer compras de afán
ante el temor
se queden sin estos suplementos para
navidad y de fin de año por eso la
urgencia de llegar a un acuerdo entre
tanto y la pregunta también es aquí será
que estas escenas se van a repetir si no
hay un acuerdo entre el reino unido y la
unión europea para una salida negociada
de la unión europea estamos a pocos días
de que se venza este periodo de
transición y todavía no hay humo blanco
de si habrá o no habrá acuerdo